ladies and gentlemen
council is all uh hopefully you can hear
me and the mic's working
no mike's
no i can't see
okay can you hear me now good
um welcome to the annual meeting of the
council and um
it's really good to see you all
physically in person and boy haven't
some of us changed i tried my suit on
today
it's quite tight but um but it is good
to see you
may first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements for tonight
our toilets are situated outside the
meeting room if the firearm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
please mark yourself as present on the
moderngov.app
if you haven't already done so i believe
you're all in now counsellors
should keep their face mask on unless
they're speaking
if you wish to speak please indicate to
the chair and move to the vacant lectern
if you wish to just nominate or second a
nomination without making a speech
please just raise your hand councillors
should remain in their seats and observe
the two metre social distancing rules
at the end of the meeting please leave
the meeting room as quickly as possible
and do not congregate inside the meeting
room
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed
by the council to have consented to
being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
um i wasn't expecting to make a speech
but i've
just been told i have to do one so i've
quickly done one not that i need to
write it down
um i think at the end of the day we all
think these meetings run seamlessly and
that actually being a chair you just sit
here and everything runs really well
um it wouldn't be the case if it wasn't
for the people that assist
us as councillors and also me as the
chair so the first person i'd like to
thank is pauline taylor who's the civic
officer
who's now moved on to retirement i wish
her all the best she's been
absolutely outstanding in a role and i'm
sure that was the case for the chair
people
that actually preceded me um
now the other people are here so they'll
probably get embarrassed emmy ewell
roberts carmichael jan robertson mandy
smith now thank you for all you do in
the background
and again it's really hard work because
when things come up
in council and i need the answers these
are the people that find those answers
pretty quickly
so thank you for everything you've done
for me
of course um see your ceo doesn't get
away with it uh thank you for your wise
counsel for keeping me on track
um it is appreciated and was valuable
thank you
um of course i've got a an excellent
vice chair
um councillor paul eppinyong and i thank
you for all your support this year
and for standing in for me when i
couldn't make certain events thank you
very much
um i wish i could have done more
obviously it's been a very very
strange year in which we've all had to
sacrifice
not go out as the chair that's been
really difficult because
part of being a chairman is to actually
go out and represent the
suffolk the mid-south district council
whenever possible
and of course i've been denied that this
year having said that
we've still gone to lots of virtual
events and they've been really
interesting
and i think actually um we've still
spread the word
that this is a great council doing great
work and great people are behind
it so thank you for all that you've done
also thank you for helping me support
the charity
which was the stone market dementia
action group
again we've raised their profile and i'd
like to thank
thank the the councillors that helped me
by using locality
grants to help that particular charity
throughout the year is very much
appreciated
and your help went a long way to help
people within the district so thank you
and thank you individually to the
councillors that actually helped me
with a christmas card appeal where you
helped put money into that account
and also for the people that want their
houses uh
taking photographs of by drones which we
will do now we've got sunny climate and
we're allowed at the house
so thank you without you groups like
this especially in the current climates
would suffer um above all though i'd
like to thank all of you
individually for all the assistance
you've given me irrespective party
side of the house throughout the year
and for the way in which you conducted
yourselves
during the council meetings that i've
chaired thank you you certainly set a
professional image and and it's evident
you know this is a serious
serious council and thank you for
everything you've done and uh thank you
for allowing me to be your chairman
okay moving on
[Applause]
so can i move to the agenda please
please can i have nominations for the
position of chairman of the council
council miller
yes you can
can you hear me yeah yeah
it gives me great pleasure to propose
councillor paul eppenyong as chair of
this council
i have known councillor eppinyong for
several years and i've been very
impressed on how he has dealt with
issues not just on mid-suffolk district
council but stone market town council
also
councillor epponyong became the first
stone market tell mayor to serve for a
period of 18 months
a period which he served with
distinction to all members of the public
in stone market and which we were very
grateful
council repping young has also been able
to use his extensive experience
as a businessman to deal with difficult
issues of council business
and i must admit in all my times when i
sat on committees with coach rep and
yong
i've always found his input extremely
helpful
and useful to council business thank you
chair can i please ask for a second
thank you thank you would you like to
speak as well
um yes thank you everyone i would just
like to
affirm the words of
of my colleague and i'm very happy to
second
councillor epping young as chairman of
this council
i have known him for about um
probably about six years now and paul
has always been
fair sensitive he sees the small picture
and the big picture
and um he will be a wonderful chairman
thank you very much
thank you councilman are there any
further
nominations counselors
yes please please do
[Music]
the role of the chair is a very
important role and i think it's one
where you have to show complete and
utter
fairness to everybody within the council
chamber
regardless of political party it's in a
a political role
and the role is to represent the council
and to
be proud of everything that happens
within mid suffolk and be a very good
representative
for all councillors regardless of party
i think any of the councillors in this
room would make a good chair
and i would be very happy to propose i
am very happy to propose
councillor warboys i think he would make
an excellent chair
and he's shown in his commitment to the
council to date
how much he cares about mid suffolk and
how he
really values the opinions of everybody
thank you chair
thank you council rebound do we have a
second to please
councillor field
thank you
are there any further nominations
thank you and ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair so we're going to vote
for councillor paul eppingham first
and then we'll take a vote for
councillor warboy's second so if
you can all vote on the modern.gov app
first
for councillor paul eppinyon thank you
i don't see it
[Music]
okay
so
have you voted
okay can i take your vote verbally then
please
for or against thank you
councillor welum
do you would you like to place it
verbally
that's fine i can take oh it's just come
through
okay that is 17 4 and 17 against
can we now vote for councillor warboys
please
[Music]
uh um that is 1717 would you like to
exercise your casting vote
uh yes i will i'll vote for councillor
paul atkin penang
chair that is kerry thank you i declare
councillor ek penang
duly elected
all right so
i counselor paul ekpanel having been
duly elected to the office of chairman
of mid-suffolk district council declared
that i take the office upon myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
i undertake that in performing the
functions of chairman
i shall observe the suffolk local code
of conduct as adopted by the council
wow
okay firstly i would like to thank
councillor muller and councillor
feliming for seconding me for the
position
of chair of the council it was very
humbling
to hear their kind words i also like to
thank my fellow councillors for
supporting me
i am truly honored to be elected as
chairman
i would also like to give thanks and pay
tribute to the outgoing chair councillor
humphreys
he has tackled the role with military
position as you would expect
and will be a hard act to follow
he has been an excellent chair and a
credit to mick suffolk
he has had to chair the council through
the most challenging
and unprecedented times and has
demonstrated real professionalism and
commitment
throughout his term of office
it has been a privilege to be his five
chair so thank you barry thank you
when i was asked what charity i wish to
support this year
there was no question in my mind as to
which one it would be
the charity i have chosen to support
is the east england children's hospice
i have chosen this particular charity
because of the work that they do
which strikes a call a very personal
cord with my family
who have had to use the services of such
an organization
when our son was diagnosed with leukemia
particularly important is that each
offers families flexibility
and control over where their where they
receive their care and support
including where their child dies at home
in hospital or at one of their three
hospitals
with only a six of their income coming
from statutory sources
each has a heavy reliance on fundraising
so i look to my fellow councillors to
support me
as much as they can to raise money for
this worthwhile cause
thank you all again for nominating me as
chairman i look forward to
and i'm very proud to be representing
this council for the next
municipal year and will do so to the
best of my judgment and ability
thank you i would now like to move to
item two
on the agenda
and this is the election of vice
chairman of the council
may i have nominations for vice chairman
councillor flatman
piggy pardon yes please do
um you don't you don't have to go to the
back one counselor you can use this one
here
um i'd like to nominate councillor barry
humphries
because he has shown well great
leadership for this council over the
past year in very very difficult times
and i think he it would be great if he
could actually have a chance now to go
out into the community
now that we're all free and i think he's
going to be a great asset
to councillor eppinyon thank you
you have a second app counselor
thank you
are there any further nominations
council ebony
do you wish to say anything counselor
eben
thank you
thank you chair um again there will be
two votes so councillors if
you can open the vote for councillor
humphreys that vote is now open thank
you
chair that is a tie so again the vote is
now open for councillor
norris if cancers could vote thank you
there might be a slight delay it is
there it's coming through
it is i think it's just a delay because
i
i can see it should come through if you
refresh
yeah there we go i i can actually see it
on my system so i think it is there it's
just slow coming sorry
yeah it should now be in blue
uh
chair that again that is a tie so would
you like to exercise your casting vote
yes i would and my vote is caught in
favor of council humphreys
okay that is then carried thank you
thank you
so i declare councillor barry humphreys
duly elected
and invite council humphreys to sign and
read the declaration of acceptance of
office
mr thank you
[Applause]
hi councillor barry humphries having
been duly elected to the office of vice
chairman
of mid-suffolk district council declared
that i take the office upon myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability i undertake that's in performing
the functions of vice chairman
i shall observe the suffolk local code
of conduct as adopted by the council
thank you
councilman matheson
that's being addressed thank you yeah is
that better
do i need to sit a bit closer to the
microphone
okay is that better
yes okay right so
we'll move to item three on the agenda
apologies for absence
chair everybody is present so there are
no apologies thank you
that's fantastic thank you
item number four declaration of interest
by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
okay there are none so we will move to
item five on the agenda
which is item mc oblique 21
oblique 1 which is to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held
on march 25th 2021 for accuracy only
i have already been notified of some
typographical
errors and an error with the name of the
portfolio
holder on pages 14 15 and 16
these have been amended are there any
more issues with the accuracy
okay in that case can i have a proposal
for the minutes thank you councillor
hattingham and
a secondary councillor brewster
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair the vote is now open and
showing in blue so please can you vote
thank you
um we have three that have not come
through councillor guthrie councillor
willem
council warboys have you voted and it's
just slow no
um so would you like to take make your
vote verbally
thank you and councillor warboys
would you like to make four thank you
that that chair is
unanimous thank you thank you
so uh that that's carried um so we'll
move
now to uh item six which is item
mc oblique 21 oblique 12. oblique 2
chairman's announcement i refer you to
the paper which is to be noted
and we're going to move on to item
number seven
the leaders announcements i would like
to invite councillor molly to present
her update please
uh good evening councillors
i would like to begin by saying how
lovely it is to see you all again
in the flesh after so long i'm relieved
to see you all safe and well
after such a traumatic 14 months
let me begin by being the first to
congratulate you
council right ping young and councillor
humphreys
on your election councilor could you put
your microphone a bit closer to you
thank you
i would also like to thank you barry for
your sterling service to the council
during such an
unusual year and can i also begin by
congratulating our various district
councillors
who have either retained or become
county councillors in the last few weeks
congratulations and i know you will fly
the flag for the residents of
mid-suffolk within the county council
and of course congratulations to
councillor hicks for being reconfirmed
as leader of the conservative group
at suffolk county council to councillor
stringer
in a similar way as leader of the green
liberal democrat and independent group
at the county council
and also to councillor passmore for his
re-election
for his third time as police and crime
commissioner for suffolk
these are unfamiliar soundings
surroundings for us
as as a council meeting i'm extremely
grateful to our own officers and the
staff at wested park
for making this possible and for
ensuring we can continue to webcast our
meetings
we usually only come here to western
park for conferences
and elections i must though
express my dismay that we are having to
meet like this tonight
it should not have been necessary it is
a waste of public funding and in my
opinion
is not appropriate it is fantastic to
see the country and our district
carefully unlocking from covid and so
far
being able to proceed smoothly along the
government's roadmap
we are though still in a pandemic and so
i am hugely disappointed in the failure
to understand the importance of local
democracy
and therefore to make a simple extension
to the legislation that would have
enabled this meeting to take place
virtually
i know many of you have been personally
shielding during lockdowns
due to your own ill health or
vulnerabilities and i know that many of
you have also caring responsibilities
for loved ones in a similar position
i therefore apologize for putting you in
such a difficult position
by asking you and the public to attend
this meeting tonight
our response to the pandemic in quickly
ensuring that local democracy could not
just continue
but also to thrive online through
virtual team
meetings webcast to youtube has been
fantastic
it has strengthened and broadened access
to local democracy
at the most important time and enabled
us to continue to function
and deliver for all our residents
throughout this difficult 14 months
we stand and have stood shoulder to
shoulder with our local mps
and our health colleagues who are
guiding us through this
we have of course put in place all the
covid19 mitigations that you have become
used to
and would expect in order to keep you
and the public safe
safe but that of course misses the point
we are responding to the government's
call for evidence
to not just make this point but also to
stress that the time has come for all
local councils
to have the power to choose how we meet
whether in person
or online or in a hybrid manner rather
than being dictated to by whitehall
my disappointment is even more acute in
relation to this issue
because i do have to update you this
evening about our own
calvin kovid outbreak situation in
mid-suffolk
as you will be aware there has recently
been an outbreak at watisham base
this has also extended into the
neighboring neighbouring
community particularly around needham
market
we have been working in conjunction with
public health to establish a mobile
testing unit on the car park
of our former hq site and this has been
in place since saturday and will
continue
for at least the whole of this week we
will of course continue to keep our
local residents and councillors
supported and informed
finally i wasn't going to spend time
tonight talking in detail about the year
ahead
but i do want to thank all of the
counsellors who were able to take past
part in the workshops last week
i was really proud of the energy passion
and compassion
expressed by all of our counsellors
it was also great to hear so much
agreement and commonality
those workshops will help shape our
actions and delivery over the next 12 to
24 months
however there is still the opportunity
to have your say
any counsellors who weren't able to
attend or who wish to contribute
their ideas and views in relation to any
of the workshop themes
that they weren't in can still do so
you have all received an email from
deborah largent with a short form to
complete
if you wish to submit your ideas then
please can i ask you to do so
by the deadline of this wednesday if you
haven't already
thank you very much chair so molly are
there any questions for councillor
morley
councillor ebon
thank you very much chair thank you
councillor morley
um if i may just as well add my
congratulations as well to those
mid-suffolk district council members
um that were elected to the county
council that's
councillors hicks fleming and gould
councillors otton and scarf
and councillors stringer melham and
wellam
could i ask um and and also if i may can
i thank the election team here at mid
suffolk who i
think did a fantastic job under really
um difficult circumstances so thank you
for that
could i ask with regards to um voting
mid suffolk ran a postal vote campaign
where we um encouraged people of a
certain age and with certain clinical
issues to register for a postal vote so
that they wouldn't miss out in terms of
their democratic right and could i ask
whether
such a campaign will continue and will
be extended perhaps to other groups
um secondly could i also ask you you
mentioned council morally about sort of
effectively lobbying for hybrid meetings
and
um remote meetings um could i ask if
there's anything that we as councillors
can do to add to that
thank you very much thank you councillor
eben
um i can't answer your question about
the postal voting
that's that's not within my my remit
but i i will ensure that the question
gets answered outside this meeting
sorry just remind me
um yes we are preparing a document and
we will make
um it available for people to to see
before we submit it
thank you thank you councillor carter
i'll make sure that that's uh
communicated outside this meeting
is
[Music]
thank you councillor carter uh well
councillor carter for my
major say um in fact you would have been
able to use the lectern to
just to your left if you needed to um
but
i guess it's wonderful that you have
such a loud voice and we can all hear
you
loud and clear
and there's also a remote mic which um
henrietta's got at the back there so
if anyone doesn't need a mic she will
bring it to you
okay
welcome counselor okay
thank you counselor molly um right
uh we're now going to move to item
number eight which is designation of
committees
and joint committees so we're going to
look to appoint the following committees
and joint committees so
these are mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny committee
development control committee a
development control committee b
planning referrals committee mid-suffolk
licensing and regulatory committee
joint audit and standards committee and
joint appointments committee
could i have a proposal to appoint all
the committees listed on the agenda
councillor casten thank you and can have
a second please
councillor molly thank you i will now
ask the corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair councillors the vote is
now open if you'd like to place your
vote
please thank you
chair that is um
unanimous unanimously for thank you
thank you
so that is carried
we'll now move on to item number nine
that's uh item
mc oblique 21 oblique three
political balance and composition of
committees
i refer you to appendix b in the table
to papers
i would like to invite emily ewell
monitoring officer to introduce paper
mc oblique 21 oblique 3.
good evening councillors i'm pleased to
present the report which asks the
council to first
agree the numerical allocations of seats
i.e the political balance
of the committees and then to approve
the cash is contained in the tabled
papers we don't have any substitutes put
forward so it is just the substantive
members
of the committees that you're asked to
approve this evening and then
substitutions will work in the normal
way
in accordance with the constitution
chair i'm very happy to answer any
questions and would look for a proposer
and a seconder for the recommendations
thank you
thank you emily are there any questions
in which case could i have a proposal
please
counselor molly and could i have a
secondary council brewster
uh there uh so i would now like to ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote please
thank you chair that that vote is now
showing in blue if members would like to
vote
for against or abstention thank you
chair we have a result that is 33 4 and
one
against thank you okay thank you very
much and that is
therefore carried
that takes us then to the next item on
the agenda
which is item 10 election of chairs and
vice chairs of committees
so we want to go to to elect a chair and
vice chair for the following committees
and joint committees so mid-suffolk
overview and scrutiny committee
development control committee a
development control committee b
mid-suffolk licensing and regulatory
committee
joint audit and standards committee and
finally
the joint appointments committee may i
have
nominations for the chair of overview
and scrutiny
uh committee please counselor ebony
thank you and could i have a second
council flatman
thank you are there any further
nominations
for chair of this committee
no and then which case uh i will now ask
the
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
okay um thank you chair that was so if
you could all vote for cancer
a well and for against or abstention
thank you
bit slow coming through but it will be
there
councillor phillips are you able to vote
no would you like to place that verbally
would you like to vote verbally thank
you
and cancer stringer are you
okay so chair that is a unanimous sleeve
thank you very much so councillor wellam
is duly appointed chair of overview and
scrutiny committee
so may i now have um nominations for
the vice chair of the overview and
scrutiny committee
um if i could have a proposal councilman
thank you and do you have a second death
council flatman
thank you
and do we have any other further
nominations counselor ebern
okay and do you have a secondary for
that
counselor phil thank you
okay are they any other nominations
no okay i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
so again councillors we have two votes
so the first vote will be for councillor
castin
um so if you could place your votes now
that the vote is now open
thank you
so chair that is 16 and 16 votes against
and 18 four so we don't need to go to
the second
vote because that is carried on that
thank you very much
uh there's a counselor carsten is duly
appointed vice chair of overview and
scrutiny committee
well done councillor okay
so uh move on to the next committee
which is development control committee a
may i have nominations for the chair of
that committee
please
counselor guthrie
yes councillor hicks
uh and council hading him are you
seconding thank you very much
are there any other further nominations
councillor ebon
and do you have a seconder for that tell
you
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote please
so again chair um there will be two
votes
so we're going to vote for
councillor hicks first please
chair that is a tie so we will do the
second vote for councillor mansell
which is now open
chair again that is a tie so would you
like to exercise
your casting vote yes i will and i will
cast my vote in favor
i have a second there counselor field
thank you are they are there any further
nominations
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please
thank you chair again there are two
votes the vote for councillor mueller
is now open if um councillors would like
to cost their vote
thank you
that's the scarf are you having problems
would you like to place yours verbally
so would you like to place it verbally
against okay chair um
the the results of the voting are 18 4
and 16
against so we don't need to um do the
second vote for that that is carried
okay so therefore
um councillor muller is duly appointed
the vice chair
of development control committee a
so may i have nominations for the chair
of development control committee b
please
counselor byron
thank you and do we have a second year
for that please
counselor flatman okay are there any
further nominations
councillor ebern
okay and do you have a secondary
counselor field
thank you okay
there not being any further nominations
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you again jacare there will be two
votes so
cancer um the vote for council guthrie
will be the first vote so and is now in
progress thank you
actual screen is hanging at the moment
so i can't i can't update anything
[Music]
okay we're in business yeah it's coming
up now
sorry it's just been really slow
okay cancer scarf we'd like can i take
yours
against okay chair so that is a tie
again
so we will do the second vote for
councillor war boys this time please
okay so if councillors would like to go
to the vote it should now be showing in
[Music]
blue
that again is a tie so would you like to
exercise your casting vote
uh yes i would and uh i cast my vote in
favor of councillor guthrie
who is duly appointed chair of
development control b committee being
may i have nominations for the vice
chair of development control committee b
please grab a proposal council muller
and second down councillor hadingham yep
are they any further nominations
councillor ebern
okay counselor you're seconding
thank you i would like to now ask the
corporate manager for governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote please
so thank you chair the vote for
councillor humphreys
is now open if you'd like to cast your
votes
so pratt are you having problems are you
voted sorry it's just come through
okay chair that is another tie so um
we need to vote for councillor warboys
please okay
that vote is now open
the geek are you able to vote or is it
just taking its time
okay chair that is a tie as well so are
you
um wanting to exercise your casting vote
uh yes i will and i'm gonna
exercise my vote in favor of councillor
humphreys
and so counselor humphrey is duly
appointed vice chair of development
control committee b
may i have nominations for the chair of
licensing and regulatory committee
uh could i have a proposal please
counselor fleming
a second councillor harrigan okay
any other nominations councillor ebon
and secondary thank you councillor field
will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
please thank you chair so we again
two votes um council the vote for
councillor guthrie is now
open if councillors would like to cast
their vote thank you
councillor turner are you able to vote
that's that's fine um chair that is a
that is a tie so we will do the
um vote now for cancer otton okay
hmm
so
councillor geek um sorry you don't seem
to have your vote have you voted or is
it just slow coming through
chair that is a tie again do you wish to
exercise your casting vote uh yes i do
and that will be in favor of councillor
guthrie
and so countless guthrie is duly
appointed chair of licensing and
regulatory committee
may i have nominations for the vice
chair of licensing and regulatory
committee please
could i have a proposal counselor burn
okay thank you and do you have a second
for councilmember councillor brewster
thank you
thank you are there any other
nominations
councillor ebern
thank you and council field seconding
thank you i will now ask the
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
please
again chair it will be two votes the
vote for councillor muller
is now open if you would place your
votes thank you
reburn um are you having problems or is
it just slow coming through
it's done okay slow coming through and
counselor carter
have you managed to vote or is it just
slow coming through
okay i'll wait i'll wait another couple
seconds
cancer carter it doesn't seem to
register so can i take your vote
verbally please
thank you chair that is a tie so we will
need to go to the second vote for
councillor otton
please go ahead thank you
so that vote is now open councillors if
you'd like to place your vote
counselor brewster are you having
problems or have you voted
should be through thank you good
question and counselor madison are you
having problems or should is it just
okay can i take your vote man manually
then
okay thank you chair that is a tie
again so again will you exercise your
casting vote
uh yes i will and i will exercise it in
favor of councillor muller
and so councillor muller is duly
appointed vice chair of licensing and
regulatory committee
may i have nominations for the co-chair
of joint audit and standards committee
could i have a proposal counselor ebon
thank you and we have a second for that
thank you councillor field are there any
further nominations
counselor hattingham
councillor okay no second
councillor fleming thank you
right i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair again it will be two
votes the vote for councillor wall boys
is now
open thank you
are you able to vote because no
yeah it's not it does it's coming up
it's just come up yeah
sorry it seems to be a bit of a time lag
the warboys are you able to vote
is it coming through
chair that is the tie so we will go to
the second vote
for councillor muller please proceed
vote is now in progress thank you
are you able to vote
cancer it still hasn't come through so
can i take it um verbally please
it should come through okay
chair that is again is a tie um so
do you wish to cost your casting vote
uh yes i do and that will be in favor of
councillor muller
so councillor muller is duly appointed
co-chair of the joint audit
and standards committee
may i have nominations for the co-chair
of
joint appointments committee that right
another one yes grab a proposal for that
please
council brewster in
i'm sorry i can't who are you proposing
okay thank you and we have a second
there
council casting thank you are there any
other nominations
if not then count them all is duly
elected for that post
i beg your pardon
so i can't hear
okay okay right uh so um i will now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair that vote is now open if cancers
would like to place their vote
thank you
stay there but you should now be able to
to place your votes
counselor norris are you able to place
your vote or would you like to do it
verbally
oh actually it's just come through thank
you so chair that the voting is 21 in
favor
and 13 against thank you
so councillor molly is duly appointed
co-chair of
joint appointments committee
[Music]
so i think we could now move on to item
11.
right so item 11 mc oblique 21
oblique 4 appointments to outside bodies
for
the 20 21 22 i refer you to appendix a
in the tabled papers
i would like to invite the leader to
introduce paper mc
oblique 21 oblique 4 and move the
recommendation in the report
council morning
happy to present this report
i don't think there's anything much for
contention on here
apart from there's obviously two
items the east-west rail consortium
and the haven gateway partnership
where there are two two nominations
my feeling is that both of these roles
are
um portfolio holder roles
and therefore both should
council of brewster i noticed that
councillor scarf is nominated as a sub
on the haven gateway partnership which i
do find a bit
surprising because in january
councillor councillors ebern welham
scarf
pratt and morrison all voted to
withdraw from the haven gateway
partnership
as they felt that they could not
demonstrate value and relevance
and so i do feel that
having somebody that really believes in
this business partnership
especially given the strategic
importance of it to both our gateway 14
development and to the wider freeport
east
is absolutely crucial to our council
and in view of the strategic importance
i place on it
i'm happy to stand as sub for that
outside body thank you
uh do we have a second day for flight
if i can ask for second is thank you
that council bruce
thank you um are there any amendments
councillor ebern
[Music]
um thank you chair if i may ask a
question um
and and firstly just to um say the
reason i voted against the
the partnership at the january meeting
was because of the complete lack of
information and the uncertainty
of the member that was on that um had
that
appointment in not understanding or not
appreciating
um uh what that entailed and how much it
was and so on and so forth
and the fact that when he'd gone to the
um scrutiny committee
he'd recommended and we'd not be on it
so the fact that there wasn't enough
information at that
that meeting at that time but my
question is
um given the with this item coming
forward now
um will the leader show how
she is going to extend a greater spirit
of working together
than has been shown so far in this
evening's meeting
given that the councillors the
hard-working and dedicated councillors
sitting on this side of the chamber
that represent half of our residents
have so far
been sidelined with regards to even vice
chair positions on on the committees
thank you chair
uh council molly do you accept the
amendment
oh it's a question could you respond to
that
[Music]
i can't say that i've got anything extra
to add to that
the um it is what it is
okay council willem
council willem is it is a question or an
amendment that you're proposing
i'd like to propose an amendment okay to
the list of
so you see to wearing it sorry i'd like
to propose an amendment to the list of
appointments to outside bodies
i propose that a member of mid-suffolk
district council be appointed as an
observer
at meetings of the trustees of the
mid-suffolk citizens advice
all right we did have a second
which was counselor brewster that's okay
i propose that a member of mid-suffolk
district council be appointed as an
observer at meetings
of the trustees of the mid-suffolk
citizens advice
this was a recommendation to the council
from
the mid-suffolk overview and scrutiny
committee
where it received cross-party support
making this appointment
was agreed at the january full council
earlier this week
this year where it received cross-party
support
such an appointment would put
mid-support back in line with baba
district council
who appoint an observer to sudbury
district citizens advice
thank you uh council william do you have
a second countless golf
okay
i'd be very happy to second council of
wellings amendment i think
uh we do deserve an observer status at
mid suffolk cab
uh indeed when mid-south at cab came to
the overview and scrutiny committee
they actually were quite happy for us to
have an observer on that committee
as councillor welum pointed out this was
passed by
both the committee and council and i
think it is
high time that we had an observer on
this body thank you
you countless golf counselor molly do
you accept the amendment
thank you chair um no i do not accept
the amendment
at the committee meeting sorry not
committee full council in january
where this was discussed it was agreed
that it would go to
cabinet for discussion prior to a
decision being made
and that will be coming up very shortly
thank you
okay
okay so uh we can now move into debate
on the
amendment who would like to start
counselor orton
yes
thank you very much chairman and before
i start i cannot contain myself to say
how very disappointed
i am that this council
is not adopting what might be considered
best practice
by actually at least involving some
members
of both parties within this council
afraid i just had to get off my chest
i would like to support the amendment it
seemed to me
when the report from overview and
scrutiny
there were considerable number of
members who felt that
it was very important that this council
had an
um observer on mid suffolk citizens
advice bureau
we all know the amount of work that the
cabs have had to deal with over the
pandemic
situation people losing their jobs
having to claim for
benefit and i really feel that it's
important
that we have a direct person there to
support
and and report back to exactly what they
are having to cope with
thank you chairman thank you councillor
otton
is anyone else wishing to speak
if not then i would ask the council of
willem and councilman morley if they
wish to add anything further
council wellam
please counsel molly
yes i will just add a couple of other
things um
we do place um really high importance on
the work that the citizens advice bureau
do
it is not that we do not wish to have an
observer on there
we already have several of our
colleagues
who are represented represented
on there and i myself together with
council flatman and councillor uh
hadingham
have been to meet with them and discuss
with them and
our officers have regular meetings with
them so we know exactly what's going on
there
and the issues that they face
[Music]
this is not about us not valuing the
work that the cab does this is
absolutely
about finding the right way of getting
that
discussion and engagement and an
observer
has no status on there and
can make no decisions and can make no
judgments
so i am really confident
that the work that our officers does do
together with myself councillor flatman
for communities
and councillor hadingham for housing
we have the knowledge and we can work
better with them
through our office and mediums
counselor
thank you chair i'm i'm really surprised
i cannot believe that this cannot be
accepted
officers and councillors whose names
the leader has mentioned do not have a
remit to report back to count
to council if we had an observer
appointed by council then they would
report back
members of the administration who
represent wards within stone market
supported this at overview and scrutiny
and i believe
also at um at council where
it was agreed that this was the proper
way forward
if this is if this amendment is not
supported
what sort of message does that give back
to the manager
at citizens advice in stone market thank
you
thank you councillor we'll now i will
now ask the corporate manager for
governance and civic office to conduct a
vote on the amendment
thank you chair so we are voting just on
the amendment here and that is to
appoint an observer to mid-suffolk
citizens advice
that vote is now open if councillors
would
wish to place their vote thank you
so
so
chair can you make sure you vote as well
please
it hasn't right here we go
councillor hicks are you having problem
against thank you chair that is a
tie 1717 would you like to exercise your
casting vote
uh yes i will and i will be cutting it
against
okay that is lost that amendment is lost
okay so so the amendment is lost and
um we go back to councillor molly's
recommendation
yeah so chair when it comes to this
because we've got two nominations for
the east west rail consortium
and two nominations the haven gateway
partnership i will take those two
um outside bodies separately and then
lastly we'll take the rest of the paper
on block so
the first vote will be for the east west
rail consortium and the first vote is
for councillor brewster
um and then once that's carried out if
it's a tie we will then go to cancer
mansel so the first vote is for
cancer brewster to be the appointed to
the as the
outs representative on the outside body
east-west rail consortium
that vote is now open
yeah that is a tie so we will go to the
second vote
but the vote now is for councillor
mansell to be appointed as yet
as a representative on the outside body
the east west rail consortium
that vote is now open thank you
chair that is a tie so um again
do you wish to exercise your casting
vote
i do and that will be in favor of
councillor brewster
okay councillor bruce that is carried
for councillor bluester then
um we now move on to the haven gateway
partnership and we have had
two nominations for the substitutes
we've got councillor morley
and cancer scarf we will then
again do two votes so the the um vote
for councillor moorley as substitute is
now
open if councillors would like to place
their vote thank you
councillor brewster are you able to
place your vote now
it's still not showing counsellor would
you like to place it verbally
thank you chair that is a tie so we will
go to the next vote which is councillor
keith scarf
as the substitute on the haven gateway
partnership
that vote is now open if councillors
would like to place their vote
i don't know
counselor brewster are you having
problems again
can i take your vote verbally then
please
against
cancer stringer are you also having
problems
and counsellor richardson
okay so
again chair that is a tie so do you want
to exercise
your casting vote yes i do and that will
be in favor of councillor molly
okay chair that that is carried super
thank you
do we go back to the paper now so so
chair we now move to the vote for the
rest of
the remaining paper where the placings
are tabled if councillors would like to
now exercise their vote for the rest of
the paper that vote
is now open
[Music]
[Music]
we have still got quite a lot of
councillors that haven't yet voted
um yes so it is the vote is at the top
in blue so if cancers could look at the
top
sorry
yes the whole the rest of the the paper
as tabled
okay councillor field are you having
problems or
okay can i take your vote verbally
against
councillor matthewson are you having
problems or is it
just being slow
you have now voted actually counsellor
and councillor warboys
we're still awaiting your vote
okay um the results are in it's 18
4 and 14 against two abstentions
chair so that is carried
that is carried we that shall now move
on to
item number 12. this is the appointment
of councillors to the shared revenues
partnership joint committee
the nominations have been tabled could i
have a proposal
councillor morley and could i have a
secondary
council brewster i will now ask the
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
please thank you chair that vote is now
open if councillors could place their
vote
thank you
councillor phillips are you able to
place your vote no would you like to
give that verbally
against and counselor calfri
are you also having problems
four okay so we have
um the vote is 19 4
14 against and one abstention
that is carried
so now to item number 13 appointments to
the suffolk joint standards board
the nominations have been tabled could i
have a proposal
counselor mauling and could i have a
second please
councillor brewster i will now ask the
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is has now
gone blue and
if you can place your votes that'd be
great thank you
councillor wellam are you having
problems
so
okay and chair that is 31 votes four two
against and one abstention
thank you that is carried
we'll move on to item 14
appointments to the joint gypsy and
travelers hearing group
council is asked to appoint four
councillors to the joint gypsy and
travelers hearing group
the nominations have been tabled please
could i have a proposal
counselor morley and could i have a
seconder counselor brewster
okay i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair so the vote for the
appointments to the joint gypsy and
travel steering group
is now showing in blue if you could
place your votes please thank you
okay would you like to
voting for lovely thank you
councillor byrne are you able to vote or
would you like to do your vote verbally
oh absolutely it's just come through
okay so that um chair is
votes 33 4 and 1 against
that is carried so we move on to
item number 15.
appointments to council working groups
council is asked to appoint councillors
to the following working groups as
tabled
community governance review working
group constitution working group member
learning and development working group
and local plan working group can i have
a proposal please
counsel molly seconder
brewster excuse me i will now ask the
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
please
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if you could cast your votes
thank you
so
cancer phillips oh hd he's not here so
um it's you uh the vote is 33
for so um actually cancer philip's not
here to do his vote but
they're still carried by a fair majority
chair
okay so that is carried
now we can move on to item number 16.
this is report m.c
oblique 21 oblique 5. overview and
scrutiny committee annual report 20 2021
i'd like to invite council willem to
introduce his report which is for noting
[Music]
thank you chair hopefully everyone's had
a chance to read through
the annual report i'd just like to thank
all of the members of the committee who
took part in these
reviews throughout the year it was a
rather odd year because
we we started just as starting the year
just as covid was coming in
we had very few meetings
we've only just had the first meeting
face to face
this morning but
i'd like to thank all of the committee
staff as well and
and all of those who have presented
reports
and taken part officers who have taken
part in
our meetings so i'm happy to answer
questions
if there are any thank you councillor
wellam are there any questions for
councillor willem
councillor mansell
yes
uh thank you um i i just like to ask um
councillor welum if he feels that during
the past year
the recommendations of the overview and
scrutiny committee
that have been recommendations for
council
such as the consideration of an observer
on the citizens of rice bureau
have been followed through in a timely
and appropriate manner
thank you thank you councilmember
this was something which uh cropped up
at our meeting this morning that
uh the committee feel they get very
little feedback from
from cabinet or council and we would
like to discuss
ways of getting better feedback and of
course i'm very disappointed
particularly in in that recommendation
and even more so because there are some
see
sitting here today who voted for an
observer
on that occasion in committee and have
voted against it
today so that that's that is very
disappointing
thank you okay are there any other
questions for council wellam
okay councilwell do you have anything
else to say
are you done i'm finished thank you okay
super thank you councillor
and that report was for noting only so
we shall now move on to item number 17.
this is um mc oblique 21 oblique 6
overview and scrutiny community work
plan for 2021-22
i would like to invite councillor wellam
to introduce his report which is for
noting
big deal to say about that it's part of
the annual report
and clearly you can see that there are
some gaps and
it will be for the the new scrutiny
committee to complete the work plan
uh at its next meeting or at least to
start to fill some of those gaps
um and i'm very open to hearing from
any member of any topic that you feel
that
uh that scrutiny could usefully have a
look at
thank you chair thank you councillor
willem
are there any questions for councillor
wellam councillor ebert
um thank you very much chair thank you
councillor welland for your report
um one of the issues that's come up a
lot um recently
and and well forever as far as i'm aware
is that of rural transport
and would it be possible for scrutiny to
have a
look at that and to assess how
local residents are able to get to work
to college to
doctors appointments and so on it's
something that came up a lot to those of
you who are in the
workshops on last week um it came up in
lots of different ways there
and so is it possible for that to go on
the work plan or at least be considered
for that thank you
thank you councillory burn yes just this
morning we did discuss
the possibility of adding to the work
plan um
a review of rural transport and also
a review of the way that this council
delivers services
to the rural community thank you
okay are there any other questions for
council welum
if not um thank you very much councillor
wellam
that report was for noting only and uh
i'd like to thank council for their
forbearance during this whole
evening's proceedings and please note
that the
date of the next meeting is thursday the
22nd of july at
20 21 at 5 30 pm and
formally close the meeting at this point
thank you all very much
you